all right some good news it is a special
day for thousands of unlv grads the
university's first ceremony during the
pandemic went off this morning it was in
person
our hector mejia shows us how students
are celebrating
dude i am super stoked i'm so excited
i've been like waiting for this day it's
been three years coming i'm just really
excited
it's the excitement of graduation unlv's
first
in person during the pandemic happening
in a series of commencement ceremonies
over the next
two days i'm so happy to be with my
peers and everyone's getting their
education it's amazing how excited are
you
i can't even express i'm thrilled the
ceremonies will be held outdoors here at
samboyd stadium where families will be
watching from the stands
spaced apart it's pretty awesome i
decided to come back to school and
change my career at age 50.
so i'm changing my career to social work
and so my mom's here from colorado and
she's excited to be here and watch me
get my masters you're looking at grad
students of all ages
ranging from just 20 years old all the
way up
to 81 classes of 2021
and 2020 this is also for those students
who were not able to cross the stage
last year when the pandemic started
students like jasmine drawhorn i was
really sad so what we ended up doing was
just having an
impromptu graduation at the house and
that was pretty much all we did so to be
here today
i wasn't going to miss it unlv will be
doing ceremonies for as many as 8
000 students graduating from both
classes of 2020
and 2021 reporting from sam boyd stadium
hector mejia
8 news now